okay boys what do you think about my
costume for tonight you look Dynamite
honey I thank you I am Princess Fiona so
does that make me a prince do I have to
keep track of a crown all night no
you're Shrek the organ you mean that big
green thing no I don't want to walk
around all night with an ugly rubber
mask oh you just need to paint your face
green and that's it
ouch yeah ouch you do this every time
you go as a princess I have to go some
freak your beauty I'm the Beast your
Beyonce I'm that guy well you never want
to go shopping with me for costumes so I
get what I want and you are what comes
with it well this year I'm getting my
own costume and it's going to be tough
and manly maybe a cowboy or construction
worker you know that that's what
Michener last year right
so because of this marriage you're
basically third cousins with Shakira I
mean we don't get the free tickets but
it's fun
[Music]
what is this what's up princess I'm
Prince Charming I can't see that I got
you a donkey costume and I got Stella
cat ears I just hope she doesn't Chase
herself ah yeah you get it because she's
a dog I also found out that Princess
Fiona is supposed to wear a tiara so
here you go that whole bucket full of
them I love it
and you look so handsome it's like those
pictures of you in the Navy
have an idea why don't we put Joe down
for a nap and then we go and they're
gonna have another one we sleep I got it
I'm in okay Gloria what happened to my
hair I know please I cannot have this
conversation again yesterday time is
cruel my prince charming wig it's gone
okay what do you think handsome Hawaiian
or sexy Scotsman I can't do this right
now come on Jay this is my farewell tour
trick-or-treating in the neighborhood I
have to go out strong
or should I just do what people are
expecting stay home because you're 20.
Jay please don't be mean to Manny maybe
Stella took your week and buried it in
the yard I saw her playing with it
earlier what why didn't you take it from
her I don't understand your relationship
with her you let her lick your feet who
was that possibly hurting what am I
gonna do now Prince Charming had hair
please we don't really know that for
sure they were in cameras back then
maybe he had to be Charming because he
was bald wow
I knew my farewell tour would be
emotional but at least I can say I did
it my way you said that four times you
know he had other songs
nice costume Ben Franklin right what no
no Prince Charming oh sorry I guess I
just picture Prince Charming with hair
we all do but I lost my wig I don't have
any so well you know there are some
pretty effective solutions for that
talking about hair plugs yeah take some
from the side in the back right you
think that would work for me
good but you might want a second opinion
from an actual doctor excuse me
did you just ask that fake doctor about
her blogs no you know how you struggle
with the language Jay damage Gloria I
miss having a head full of hair and
don't act like you don't miss it too
when we got married you had four more
hairs than you do now this is not a
surprise to me what about today earlier
when we were not napping when you were a
little extra enthusiastic because you
were enthusiastic you went out and
bought costumes for all of us who were
singing for once you were not like I
don't want to do this I just want to see
that at home watch golf and eat my 10
layer deep just five five layers one
layer is enough Jay
I love that you were having fun with us
a happy husband that's what is sexy to
me so you don't think I look like Ben
Franklin
oh
that's sweet
then I'm from the hundred dollar bill my
favorite
now I look like Rod Stewart
thanks a lot
[Music]